hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
and today we're going to have a
thought-provoking if perhaps
slightly depressing episode or at least
slightly putting us in the mode of
worrying about really profound
things that is the concept of
existential risks or even lesser than
that
catastrophic or extreme risks that we
face as
a species so we all know that something
happened
in the 20th century we gained the
technological ability
to really do enormous harm to ourselves
as a species
there was always times back in history
when human beings could harm each other
but these days we can imagine human
beings
truly wreaking havoc on the whole planet
or the whole species that's what we mean
by
extreme or catastrophic or existential
risks
so today's guest is martin reese that's
lord
reese baron of ludlow he is officially a
lord in the british
hierarchy there he actually sits in the
house of lords and votes
and so forth but martin is also one of
the
leading theoretical astrophysicists of
our age she's done enormously good work
in high energy astrophysics
understanding black holes and galaxies
and things like that
but over the last decade or two he's
gained an interest
in these big questions of human life
and where humanity is going toward the
future so he's one of the co-founders of
the center for the study of existential
risks
at cambridge university and that's
mostly what we talk about today there's
a lot of risks out there of course the
first to really come on the scene was
nuclear war and that's still out there
and we talk about that one but now
there's all sorts of
bio threats as well as cyber threats as
well as artificial intelligence
not to mention the sort of natural
disasters of asteroids and
solar flares and earthquakes that could
cause enormous harm
it's a really interesting science
problem but also a
philosophical problem because you're
asking how to
judge an extremely unlikely event
versus if that event happens it would be
catastrophic for everybody
so the classic example of this is what
if the large hadron collider
created a black hole and destroyed all
the earth unlikely to happen
but do you really want to risk it this
is a really really good question so we
get into this
we get into how to deal with all these
questions but then being who we are
talking about life on earth eventually
turns into life on other planets and in
actually in the last half of the
discussion we're talking about life
elsewhere in the universe again
something that martin is a world expert
in
and we talk about why we haven't seen it
yet what forms it could take what we can
learn about life on earth
by thinking about life on other planets
so we start off with some you know
down-to-earth kind of depressing topics
but it's very optimistic
and uh action-packed there by the end so
tune in you're gonna like this one let's
go
[Music]
okay martin reece welcome to the
mindscape podcast good to be with you
so you've done a lot of work obviously
on cosmology high energy astrophysics
and so forth but
a relatively recent interest of yours
has been the future of humanity the
risks that we face and
so i thought we could we could start
just with a worked example
and we can think about how to think
about this so as a as someone who's done
particle physics in quantum field theory
my favorite worked example
is what if the large hadron collider
created either a black hole or some
exotic particle that then ate up the
earth
but and i i was surprised to learn by
reading your books that you had actually
thought about this and you were one of
the first people to really uh wonder
about this
well i got the idea from someone else
but i thought it was a good worked
example because
obviously it's very very unlikely um
but the consequence so catastrophic uh
that
i think it's not stupid to query this
and there were some people who of course
did query this and they were sort of
pooh-poohed a bit by the people at cern
or brookhaven
but um although we think it's very very
unlikely
i think it does raise a non-trivial
issue
because um uh there was a committee set
up
at cern to address this and they said
with great confidence
uh that on the basis of all theories
this
wouldn't happen um but obviously
the level of confidence you want is
something like
a billion or trillion to one given the
consequences and the reason i think it's
not trivial to worry is that
supposing you were up before an american
congressional committee
to address this issue and you said well
the
chances are a billion to one and then
they say to you
dr carol are you really saying that less
than a one in a billion chance that
you're wrong
could you say yes to that yes and so
obviously the main
risk is that our theory is completely
wrong and there's something
entirely unenvisioned a systematic could
happen
uh when you explore a part of parameter
space that's never been explored by
nature itself
i mean maybe for the benefit of the
audience could you explain a little bit
about what it would be that could go
wrong
at the lhc that would cause us all to be
killed well i think um
here i'm just quoting the other experts
one idea
is a mini black hole uh the other idea
is um turning material into what's
called strangelets
which would gradually sort of gobble up
the earth and turn it into some
compact structure and these have been
speculated about by
particle physicists no one thinks
they're likely and uh
i'm a bit inhibited talking about this
because when i have talked about in the
past there'd be newspaper headlines
saying that
uh astronomer thinks that the
accelerator will destroy the world
yeah i don't think that but i do think
that um
it's something which is quite right that
one should address
and i tried to think what i would do if
i was before the congressional committee
i think i would i would say that the
chance is very very small
but i would then say would you like to
ask me what's the chance
that something we discover this
accelerator will solve
the world's energy problems forever and
i would say that's very very small but
supposing
that you thought that was a thousand
times less small
than the chance of destroying everything
then that might tilt the balance that's
right
so that's the way i would explain why i
actually despite uncertainty about my
theory feel we shouldn't be inhibited in
going ahead with these experiments
well okay i mean that's a very good
point what if that were not
true so i think this is this is a good
thing because i want to get on the table
you know
what is the theory of thinking about
these terrible terrible things where the
chance is very small
the consequences are disastrous so
you're suggesting that one of the things
to think about
is other really really small
probabilities that might be good rather
than bad
that's right and of course we're never
possible to quantify
but of course uh um the there's a risk
in doing anything which may have
potential upsides
and so and we're used to that in the
testing of new drugs and everything
like that and so when we get to these
colossal
risks then again the same argument
applies that
we might be foregoing benefits as
freeman eisen put it in one of his
articles there's a hidden cost of saying
no
that's right the example i used in my
book uh the particle the end of the
universe was
every time you open a jar of
pasta sauce there's a chance that a
terrible mutation has happened inside
and you're going to release a pathogen
that destroys millions of people it's a
very very small chance yes
but it never stops us from opening the
jar no no but of course one does have to
be cautious
um and if you think of something which
could be globally catastrophic
then you get into philosophical
questions about
um just how much worse
an existential catastrophe is than a
very bad one
and to express this if you consider two
scenarios
one is the death of ninety percent of
the people in the world
scenario two is a death of a hundred
percent of the people in the world
and you ask the question how much worse
is scenario two than scenario one
you could say well ten percent worse the
body counts ten percent higher
but some people would say it's much much
much worse
because there you destroy the
potentiality of all future developments
and future lives
and i think it's fortunate that if we
think of all these scenarios that have
been discussed
apart from these rather crazy ones from
particle physics uh it's very hard to
imagine anything that would wipe out all
human beings
that's right but so you but you were
very careful in your formulation there
saying some people would say
that 100 is much much worse than 90 what
is your feeling
personally well i do think that's the
case because one thing which
we learn as astronomers is that
we humans are not the culmination of
evolution
it's taken four billion years for us to
emerge
from the primordial slime as it were but
uh
the time ahead even for the earth
is six billion years yeah um and
the universe has a much longer future
and uh
i'd like to quote woody allen that's
attentive very long especially towards
the end
uh so uh there's no reason to think that
we're even the halfway stage
in the emergency complexity and of
course
if intelligence is rare and
as some people think we are the only
intelligent species in the
galaxy then our fate as humans
is of galactic importance not just
terrestrial importance
because if we wipe ourselves out that
would destroy these potentialities
so i think it is much worse
to envision wiping out everyone than
having a
catastrophe which is a back to
civilization yeah there are definitely
implications of these ideas for
questions about life elsewhere
i do want to talk about that but let's
stay down here on earth for just a
minute so
i think what you're getting at and
something that i thought of as i was
reading your books is that
we talk about existential risks or these
terrible disasters but there really is a
hierarchy of them right there's
one in which a million people die which
is kind of
incredibly terribly bad one of which
most human beings die one of which
all human beings die one in which all
life
dies here on earth right and i think
it's safe to say we can
contemplate all of these right there's
there are scenarios for any one of these
actually happen
exceedingly rare but there are scenarios
yes and i think incidentally
in in my book which is called on the
future i do discuss some of these
scenarios and one
point i make is that if we think of the
um
intermediate level scenarios then they
will all cascade globally
in a way that didn't happen previously i
mean you may know the book by jared
dahmen called collapse
where he talks about the way i think
five different civilization collapsed
but uh in none of those cases did the
collapse spread globally whereas now
i think any really severe setback in any
part of the world
will have consequences because we are so
interconnected by
telecommunications supply chains air
travel and everything else
so things would spread globally and
that's
something new and another thing which
worries me very much is that i think
society is
much more fragile than in the past to
give an example
if we think back to the middle ages
when the black death bubonic plague
killed
half the population of many towns the
rest went on fatalistically
whereas now if we had some pandemic once
the
number of cases overwhelmed hospitals
there'd be a breakdown in social order
yeah people clamor for
treatment that wasn't available and
likewise
we're so dependent on electricity that
if there were
a massive cyber attack um on say the
east coast of the elect of the united
states then
to be a complete anarchy within a few
days because nothing would work
and indeed i think that is realized
because i quote in my book
a 2012 report from the american
department of defense
which talks about that scenario and says
that if it were
instigated by a hostile state it would
merit a nuclear response
that would be helpful i should i could
it's clear to me that this was going to
be uh somewhat of a downer of a
conversation i should let people know
that you're
by nature a very optimistic person
actually right i mean you have a lot of
optimism about
this breaks in it does good okay yeah so
you mentioned the interconnectedness and
how that allows potentially would allow
disasters to spread and propagate but at
the same time there's the related fact
that
technology has given us a kind of
leverage over our future
for good and for bad that we didn't have
100 years ago right the 20th century
introduced for the first time i would
say the possibility we could extinguish
ourselves
yes well nuclear initially of course
yeah that's right
so it's a different kind of question
that we really haven't
been trained to think about i mean so
you use the the number
billions to one let's say if the
probability of wiping out the earth and
maybe you got that number by taking one
over the population of the earth
but what is that the right calculus i
mean
how should is there any quantitative way
of thinking about
what we how we should measure
existential risk and how we should
respond to it
well i don't think there is i mean when
i'm an astronomer people say
do you worry about asteroids etc um and
of course
i don't very much because they are the
one risk you can quantify
pretty accurately you know whoever there
are how big they are what the impacts
would be etc but the point about
asteroids is that
um the probability of impact is no
higher now
than in prehistoric times and the uh
concerns
that we should have in the forefront of
our mind are
those which are emergent and which are
probably increasing
i mean nuclear war was the first one of
this kind
um but misuse of bio and cyber tech
are new concerns and i do think that
there is not enough attention given to
these
there's a complacency that if something
has never happened you don't worry about
it but
if it's an event which is so serious
that even one occurrence is too often
we ought to think about this and i've
been involved in setting up a center
here in cambridge to address these
extreme risks the
argument being that there's a huge
amount of effort going into
moderate risks like carcinogens in food
making trains and planes safer and all
that but
these improbable events which are
perhaps growing in probability as time
goes on
can lead us into complacency and we
really ought to think about how we can
minimize
these risks and what we would do if they
happened
and i think in our center if we can
reduce the probability of any of these
things by one
part in a thousand then the stakes are
so high that we live more than earned
our keep
that's right i i'm morbidly fascinated
by
solar flares uh which are certainly a
natural phenomenon
that has happened many times but i met a
lawyer who had worked on a commission
where they thought about this and he he
was very concerned about the idea that
once every thousand years
there's a solar flare that would be big
enough to wipe out the entire electrical
grid
here on earth and so it's kind of a
combination of a naturally occurring
thing
and a vulnerability that we have
invented for it but again the time
scales are things that we're not
adapted to dealing with no that's right
but that's an example of something where
solar flares can affect satellites for
instance they can be
hardened to minimize that impact and
it's worth doing but you're right in
saying that there are some
natural phenomena whose consequence is
greater now
because we depend on electricity more
and of course the consequence of an
earthquake in tokyo
is more now it would have been 300 years
ago
because of the number of people involved
and well and in los angeles where i live
of course yes you know the buildings
won't fall down because the buildings
are now cleverly constructed but
we will not have electricity or water
for a long time
if the earthquake hits in the right
place and that's the real worry
you're safe here in cambridge right no
earthquakes that's right there was a
reported one of magnitude 2.8 in england
a few times ago
and uh it's reported that budget rigor
fell off his perch but nothing much
worse than that happens
that would not even be reported right
where i'm from so
but there's also a philosophy question
uh here that
i thought you highlighted in the book
even when you use phrases like a billion
to one chance
yes what does that mean right because
it's not like you've done it a billion
times
absolutely and seen it happen once
so how do we interpret phrases like
there's that kind of probability well of
course
there are some contexts where it is
meaningful i mean if you
uh if you have something where you you
know um
roulette wheel is being turned or
something like that right then you can
quantify it but
of course as you say we can't quantify
any events probability if it hasn't yet
happened
right um and and that's the reason why
we may tend to underestimate
so we can't quantify well i tend to be a
subjectivist about probability i don't
know if you have strong feelings about
the philosophy of probability but
as a good bayesian i think that all
probabilities are more or less on the
same footing they're
they're related to our credence that
something is going to happen but it's
just harder to
well accurately that's not true of coin
tossing or things like that there are
some
where probabilistic estimates do make
sense and
well if you're on a basis if you're an
eternalist if you think the past present
and future are equally real
then the outcome of a coin toss is just
your ignorance about the future
you can relate it you can obviously you
know uh give a
sensible justification for having a
certain credence but
i don't think it's philosophically
different but but it does raise the
question you know the famous question in
science is what is the error
what are the error bars on your error
bars right so when you say what a
billion to one
could it be just a million one something
like that is it
is this the kind of thing that your
center worries about well i think it
could be because um
the probability that our theories are
wrong is of course
not all that small right right and it's
always hard to quit
that's why uh utter surprises can't be
ruled out
and of course they can't be quantified
yeah uh and that
is i think the reason why we can't
completely dismiss the concerns
about doing something for the first time
which has never happened in nature
of course when we talk about these
physical experiments in many cases and
indeed i'm
writing papers about this you can say
that nature has done the experiment
already
cosmic rays of high energy have collided
and nothing disastrous has happened
um and the fact that we can see stars
and white dwarfs
that are not turned into strange that's
tells us something um but if there is a
potential effect that we can create
artificially which we don't think ever
happened in nature
then we perhaps should be open-minded
yeah but we shouldn't take this too far
um i don't think there's anything in
nature which is a temperature of a
million degree kelvin
but we didn't have huge worries when we
first cooled something down
to a very low temperature like that
i suppose because we had very great
confidence in the physics then
yeah there is a it does have to do with
the
it's a theoretical not i don't want to
say bias but we
we have to proceed on the basis of
thinking that our theories
capture some truth right capture some
element of reality when we make these
otherwise
like you say we couldn't do anything
because anything would bear some
worries in some sense but i like i like
this example of the um
the large hadron collider and how we can
ask whether nature has done it already
because it gives a little bit of
an insight to people who are not in this
field that we're not flying completely
blind
there is a process through which people
do think about
how you might rule out the the
likelihood of these
existential problems and you make the
very good point in your book that
which i had not really thought of before
that we have an obligation to make that
reason
public to inform people about why we
think this right i mean you you really
you make it clear that we can't just say
let's trust
the scientists on this let we need to
spread our reasoning widely
well i think especially when the
scientists want to do the experiment
yeah and there's an interest in it so so
i think um
in that sort of case it's good to have
some independent group of people who can
sort of
reassure themselves without having any
self-interest in the experiment that
it's safe
and although i mean i i don't want to
make a big deal of the accelerator
because
i don't worry about it at all to be
honest me neither out there no
no but but i think uh in the case of bio
experiments
then this is a real issue um and need to
take one example
there were two groups which in 2011 i
think it was
one in wisconsin one in holland showed
was surprisingly easy to make the
flu virus more virulence more
transmissible and these so-called gain
of function experiments
were denied u.s federal funding for a
number of years
because there was all thought risky
because first of all
this is dangerous knowledge which
perhaps you don't want to publish that's
one question
but also does the risk of error
releasing some
something and it's now possible to
synthesize a small box virus and things
like that
and uh we do have to worry about uh
are there some experiments uh where the
risk of something going wrong
is such that you shouldn't even do the
experiment right and
these are contexts where of course there
are regulations
um and you don't just allow experiments
to do
anything they like because we are
concerned about prudential constraints
and ethical constraints
on biological experiments and there is a
regime of regulation as you know for
the use of modern ideas in genetics etc
but of course what worries me and this
is really a theme of my book
is that whatever regulations one
establishes
even if they're internationally agreed
can't necessarily be enforced
regulations on the nuclear activities
can be enforced because they require
special purpose
conspicuous facilities and so the iaea
can monitor these things but when we
think about
biological experiments they can be done
in a
lab with the facilities that exist in
many industries and many universities
and of course cyber attacks of pretty
damaging consequences can be done just
by
a lone weirdo etc and we can't really
stop experiments like that or unethical
experiments on human embryos and things
of that
being done and my concern is that um
whatever can be done will be done
somewhere by someone
whatever the regulations say and
enforcing those regulations globally
will be as hopeless as enforcing the
drug laws globally or the
tax laws globally and so that's what
scares me and if you ask me
what are the concerns i have in the next
10 years
not being too futuristic then it is
the misuse by error or by design
of biotech or cybertech yeah i think
that's exactly right
and it does it raises a couple questions
so like you say we have regulatory
standards in place on the other hand
they seem to be easy to circumvent uh
by a bad actor so uh is that an argument
for actually letting
controlled research go on so i mean you
can't just keep knowledge in the box
someone's gonna get it it must be it
might as well be ours as well as someone
else's
it's very difficult to say that we
shouldn't do research i mean you can
obviously
control the rate by controlling the
funding but you can't really stop
stop the research although obviously if
the research is intrinsically dangerous
or intrinsically unethical then
we should try and ban it but
as i say it's very hard to enforce these
bans globally
and in the context of bio and cyber i
think
there is going to be a growing tension
between
three things we want to preserve liberty
privacy and security and of course
this is uh an issue that comes up when
you talk about regulating the internet
and all that
and i think if you want to have global
regulations
you run into the problem that different
parts of the world
would adjust the balance differently i
think the chinese
would care less about privacy and more
about security
than the united states and we in europe
are somewhere in between
yeah but these are very serious issues
which
need to be addressed what is the state
of international cooperation on issues
like this
well obviously in the in health there is
the world health organization etc but
but there's
there's nothing yet established in the
uh
internet domain and the problem there of
course is that the
companies are global um and there are
vested interests in
doing certain things that other people
might not want to be done
that's right so i think the serious
problems of governance of the internet
which are being addressed but i think
enforcing them is going to be pretty
hard and
unless you have really firm controls on
the internet which is quite contrary to
the
initial spirits and hopes of tim
berners-lee and the other pioneers where
they wanted it to be
free but is it even realistic i mean
could we do it could we
really regulate the internet that easily
i'm not an expert on this
well but either but uh i think one can
have sort of censorship of content to
some extent
but uh as regards the hardware and um
minimizing the risk of hacking um i
don't know what can be done
so these are serious issues and they're
going to get more serious and i think
one of the most depressing things i find
about the way technology's developing is
that the
diffraction of efforts that go into
security
and all the things that wouldn't be
needed if we were all honest
is getting larger and larger yeah and
and it it feeds back into this idea
that the time scale this is a sort of
mismatch of time scales right there's
great promise in doing research in uh
biology or medicine or building
technological infrastructure and there's
also great dangers
but there's this worry that we race
toward the promise and the rewards first
and then try to fix up security later
right yeah is there is there some sort
of
global uh philosophical shift we might
try to work toward
to be more secure in our in our
technological advancements
well i think we should all campaign for
this but we know how
hard it is to get international
agreements um on anything
climate control and all that sort of
thing yeah yeah and
we're sitting here in the united kingdom
which has just decided to leave the
rest of europe you know it's hard to
keep international uh
organizations together and we're also
sitting here just a few days after it
was announced that jeff bezos's phone
was hacked by saudi arabia so even the
best
you know protected people in the world
it could be very vulnerable that's right
so what about um i mean maybe it'd be
useful to get on the table
a list of your favorite existential
risks
in some sense uh obviously we've
mentioned
nuclear weapons biology i'll let you be
a little bit more specific about your
top 10 well i mean um
i i think i'd want to avoid the word
existential because
the idea of wiping ourselves out is
something which
is rather only these rather science
fiction-like uh scenarios
isn't the name of your center the center
for existential risk it is and i think
extreme risks catastrophic risks would
be a more
appropriate representation what we
actually do
and uh and as i say i think these are
the uh
downsides of exciting new technologies
bio and cyber being the most prominent
and of course
another class of concerns are those
which
are emerging from our collective impact
on the planet you know the
climate change is one and um associated
loss of biodiversity
etc these are a class of long-term
threats
which everyone is aware of which are
because
of our collective actions rather than a
few bad actors
as in the other cases and again it's
very hard to
get effective action because politicians
tend to focus naturally on the immediate
and the parochial they think up to the
next election
and they think about their own
constituents etc
and it's very very hard to get
prioritization
of the action which is needed to
minimize these global risks where the
community the global community has to
act collectively
and um we're seeing this in the context
of climate change and
attempts to reduce co2 emission so i say
two things about this
what one one thing which i feel quite
strongly in the uk
context um is that uh we have set
a target of cutting our net emissions to
zero
by the year 2050. this is a very
challenging target
you will need some new technology and i
support the idea that we should have a
very strong program to develop clean
energy
better batteries and all that sort of
thing but the reason i support this
is that if we succeed then we will
reduce
our risk to zero but we're only one
percent of the world's emissions so it's
neither here nor there
but i think we in britain can claim to
have produced more than 10 percent of
the world's clever ideas up till now
and and certainly a disproportionate
number
and so if we do have a crash program
that does lead to uh cheaper energy
storage
etc uh so that india for instance
can leapfrog directly to clean energy
when it needs a grid and not build
coal-fired
power stations we will thereby do far
more than one percent right
to reducing world co2 emissions and it
will be hard to imagine a more
inspiring goal for young engineers than
to provide clean energy for the
developing
world and so that's why i think there's
a strong case for
enhancing r d there and i would say the
same thing
about um research into plant science and
bio
because feeding 9 billion people by
mid-century is another challenge
and this requires intensive agriculture
if one is to do this without encroaching
on natural forests et cetera et cetera
and here again it's going to need new
technology
um which uh the scientifically advanced
countries of which we're one
uh can make a disproportionate
contribution to so i would say that
if we prioritize research into those
areas things to do with clean energy and
storage
and into uh improved plant science etc
uh then we'll not only help ourselves
but
uh help the world so that's one thing
that's a
digression but um thinking about the
politics
then i know people who've been
scientific advisers to government
and they normally get rather frustrated
because the politicians
have their urgent agenda etc and
it's very hard to get them to prioritize
something which i think is generally
more long-term yes yes okay
but that's why i think that scientists
can have more effects
if they go public and uh you know become
small-time carl sagan's as it were
because then they do have an influence
and politicians will respond if they
think the voters are behind them
and so i think what the scientists can
do
is to uh publicize the issues
in a way that the public responds to
because then the public will influence
the politicians and the politicians will
feel that they can take these actions
without losing votes
let me give two examples uh one example
which
is very surprising is is the pope
because in 2014
there was a big scientific conference at
the vatican which
had all the world experts in climate and
people like jeffrey sachs and joe
stiglitz etc
which discussed these environmental and
climatic
threats of the world and that was input
into the pope's encyclical
in 2015 and that encyclical got him a
standing ovation at the u.n
and of course had an influence on his
billion followers in
latin america africa and east asia and
helped to ease the path to consensus at
the paris conference in december
2015 because the people in those
countries
knew that lots of people would support
this and as a more parochial
version in this country one of our less
enlightened politicians
proposed legislation to limit the
production of non-reusable plastics
drinking straws and things of that kind
and
he only did that because we'd had a year
or two ago
the blue planet two programs fronted by
david attenborough
which showed the effect of plastics in
the ocean
and especially iconic picture of a
albatross returning to his nest
and coughing up for its young not the
long four nourishment but some bits of
plastic you know
and that's become an iconic image rather
like the um
polar bear and the melting ice flow was
for the climate campaigns
and because millions of people saw that
then there was public
support for the idea of uh cutting
down the use of plastics and and that's
certainly become quite an effective
campaign
in this country so if
the public cares about something then
politicians will respond even if it's
long term and part of a global campaign
and that's why we should encourage and
value the scientists who are
able to get through to the white public
because that's more effective than being
a
science advisor in-house to government
or politicians yeah no that's a
it's a very interesting point that if a
scientist you're saying if a scientist
wants to have a real
impact on public policy then the public
should be as much of the target as
the politicians yes yes yes and uh uh
because politicians respond to what's in
the inbox
and what's in their press and what they
think their voters want obviously and so
that can be influenced by um
charismatic public figures with a
scientific background
good very good and so i want to back up
a little bit because
uh make maybe we can be a little bit
more specific
as an example of good
action here if you think that britain
wants to be
zero emissions by 2050 what would that
involve what kind of technology is that
obviously some renewable energies some
storage but
can we be more specific well i mean i
think stories more
cheaper more efficient batteries and one
has to
store the energy from day to night and
maybe even seasonally
um so we have we have to do that um i
personally think
it would include nuclear okay and of
course this is controversial
um but i i think the problem with
nuclear is there's been
no real r d in the last 20 years the
designs being used really date back from
the 1960s
and i think therefore that in
trying to develop clean energy that
should include
fourth generation nuclear and things
like small modular reactors
which could be put on the back of a
truck and
would be 100 megawatts each or something
like that and
something like that would be safer and
hopefully if they could be mass produced
more economical so i think that
nuclear is probably going to be part of
the answer without that
it's going to be harder so do you think
that the relevant the related issues
there
with uh not emissions but there's still
nuclear waste right do you think that
those are solvable
i think they they are yes i mean they're
a problem but i think they can
they can be cope with um and
incidentally i think people worry
too much about low radiation levels
another place where scientists maybe can
have a valorous impact somehow
yes explaining that this is not so bad
yes well there is a dread factor in a
in radiation isn't there yes and uh well
to
digress a bit i i think it's very
important to
have clear guidelines about the dangers
because um
suppose a dirty bomb were let off in
a street in new york or something like
that here then
people might look at some table of risks
and say we've got to evacuate this
street for the next 30 years something
like that
which may be sort of over the top but
after an event like that is not the time
to have the debates
you have to have the debate beforehand
um and of course uh an example this
which in fact we have studied
um at our center is the aftermath of the
fukushima
disaster um in japan which was serious
but the evacuation was over the top
and probably caused far more distress
than the radiation itself would have
done i didn't know that and um i'm over
evacuated
they were evacuated yes and i think
what ought to happen is there should be
sort of guidelines
um which are made available to every
city about
what the extra risk is for a particular
level
because you know if i was an old
villager in japan
i'd be prepared to accept a
significantly higher risk of cancer
in order to live out my days in my home
rather than being evacuated
and people ought to be given that choice
and of course old people might make a
different choice from
um people with young children um but
there ought to be some
rational way in which people can make
that choice
otherwise it'll be an overreaction and
this is
something which is particularly the case
in terms of radiation
this is just a human foible though right
we're very bad at talking
rationally about what happens to us in
extreme situations or
when our lives are at risk like once you
say to an old villager
if there's radiation here don't worry
about it you can stay here yeah cause
you're old and you're gonna die anyway
like this is not an easy conversation to
have
yeah yeah well i think you'd have to
actually ask them in advance you could
ask everyone you know uh if
what risk will you prepare to tolerate
if the alternative is evacuating
from your home yeah yeah but yeah i
don't know what the answer is i mean
there certainly is a philosophy question
here a whole bunch of them i mean
are there are philosophers heavily
involved in your center you know
making decisions about these big big
questions
yes well in fact uh one of our senior
people is
is a philosopher and uh is particularly
concerned about
the issue of uh future generations
because
there is a question of what discount
rate you apply and
and how much we should think about
future generations rather than as we're
now alive this is a
real question and in fact we have uh set
up a parliamentary committee
to try and raise the amount of attention
given in all legislation
to the effect in the long term
because many things we're doing are
having some effect obviously
this is um something we ought to try and
emphasize
and not discount the future as much as a
commercial transaction does
have you found politicians more or less
uh responsive to this or
i think they are responsive i mean yeah
as long as the sacrifice
for the present generations isn't too
much but it is important obviously to
think
longer term and to realize that even
though
if you make a commercial decision on an
office building or something
if you don't get your money back in 30
or 40 years you don't do it
whereas in making a decision that may
affect
the longer term future people do care
about the um
life experiences of babies born today
who'll still be alive
in the early part of the 22nd century
they get that and so we
ought to think longer term i mean it's
it's hard it's hard to predict of course
because
things are changing so fast um and one
of the
points i make in my book is is that it's
uh
at first sight paradoxical that
in medieval times when people had very
limited horizons
and when they thought the world might
end in a thousand years
they still built cathedrals that
wouldn't be finished in their lifetime
right that might seem paradoxical
whereas now we would not do something
like that right
but the reason is not paradoxical is
that
in medieval times even though they
thought the whole world might end they
thought the lives of their children
and their grandchildren were more or
less like theirs
so the grandchildren would appreciate
the completed cathedral
whereas now i think we don't have very
much confidence in predicting
what everyday life will be like 50 years
from now
given the changes that have been in the
last 50 years
and um so for that reason i think it's
rational to
not plan quite so far ahead in some
contexts but on the other hand
if there's a risk of doing something
which is irreversible long-term damage
we ought surely to care about future
generations does the example of
the environment and climate change uh
it has some sort of depressing aspects
in
how resistant certain quarters have been
to the obvious scientific evidence right
i mean
how much do you worry about
misinformation or just vested interests
resisting
the scientific findings well very much
so of course
and this is apparent in that
context of climate change where the
science is of course
very difficult and is very uncertain
we've got to accept it's uncertain
but uh i think we we do have to worry
about the reluctance to accept
scientific evidence
uh not in that context alone but in
uh the dangers of vaccines and things of
that kind right that's another example
where
where of course there's a lot of
misinformation which is
damaging being from los angeles i'm well
aware of this uh phenomenon the
epicenter of that particular phenomenon
but climate change is also an
interesting case because it's so
different in character
than something like a nuclear war or
even a terrorist nuclear bomb right it's
slowly creeping up on all of us versus a
tiny fraction every year that it would
happen
right yes is it a different strategy
different mental space you need to be in
to attack these different problems
i think it is and and i i think of
course in both cases it's hard because
in in the case of the uh the sudden
catastrophe
um then um the point is we're complacent
because
it's never happened and you think it
never will it's like in the stock market
where it keeps on rising
and you think you're on but then there's
a sudden fall there's an asymmetry
between the
speed of rises and the speed of falls
and uh similarly
you you think that things are going to
be okay
and they're not and um one of your
predecessors the darwin lecturer was
with mr taleb
who made some rather good points about
burrito distributions where
things are below average 98 of a time
and it's a long tail that's important
right yeah
and so let me let's fill in a little bit
i want to get
um the all these different kinds of
extreme risks i think is a good way of
putting it and
i think most people know about climate
change in fact we've talked about it on
this podcast
there's the nuclear threat which maybe
was larger
in the past for a large-scale nuclear
war
these days are you much more worried
about
one bomb being uh taken into a port and
blown up
yes that's right i think we can say that
during the cold war
there was a risk of a real catastrophe
because there were about 50 000 bombs on
both sides and if they had gone off
then that would have devastated much of
the northern hemisphere uh certainly
europe and
north america and there were at least a
couple of moments when it was
indeed and and i think you know when we
see what people said um
mcnamara in his later years and uh
kenzie's saying that the risk was
between one in three and evens
and all that and of course the other
false alarms that
uh we've learned about i i think we
realized
just how great the threat was and for
those of us in
in europe i think the realistic estimate
of the
risk during the cold war
was probably one in three or something
like that and
it's hard to quantify obviously but uh i
think
looking back there was a substantial
chance
and i personally think that if people
had realized that
there would have been a bit more
questioning of the
conventional policy for my part i
wouldn't have
been prepared to risk a one in three or
even one in six shards
of a nuclear exchange of that kind even
if the alternative
was a soviet takeover of the whole of
europe
uh and i i suspect many people have
taken that view but they
they didn't uh really feel that there
was this real risk
right and saying those words out loud is
also gets you in trouble politically
maybe a little bit
well it might be might have been for
some people at that time but
but but i think uh realistically i think
that that will be the trade-off
that uh we've been far better um to let
the soviets take over
um than to have the destruction of the
whole fabric of europe
um so that was the situation over the
cold war
but as you say that particular scenario
is at least in obeyance because the
number of uh
of weapons on both sides has been cut by
about a factor of ten
but on the other hand there are two
things to worry about
when i see three things uh one is that
there are
um more nuclear powers there are now ten
nuclear powers
um and the risk of some nuclear weapons
going off in the regional conflicts
in the middle east or india and pakistan
is probably higher than ever
yeah and that would be um a um regional
disaster
unless it produced some such big forest
fires that you had a nuclear winter but
it would probably just be
a reasonable effect so that's that's one
concern
but the other point is that uh the
the global threat may be just in
obeyance
because uh it could be that there's a
new standoff in the second half of the
century
between new superpowers which is handled
less well or less luckily
than the cold war was so that's a
concern and the third
uh concern is that again something we've
been
having meetings about here um that the
risk of
cyber attacks of the nuclear
infrastructure
is a new threat you know because
obviously it's very complicated
so what exactly is the threat there that
a cyber hacker could
do what could trigger trigger false
alarms or even
even trigger bombs going off you know
this is a one hopes that it's being
addressed yes
it is being addressed but on the other
hand uh in all these cyber issues
there's an arms race between the
cyber attackers who are indeed aided by
ai
and of course those who are trying to
secure things and so this is a new
concern a new class of risks uh quite
apart from old-fashioned types of false
alarms
and the lone actor who's not even a
state is a new worry for nuclear weapons
right
yes i i don't know to what extent a lone
actor could realistically
do that but uh but i think um a small
snake
states certainly and presumably it
becomes not
less likely over time right i mean as as
technology leaks out as the
information gets out as more and more
plutonium and uranium are flying around
uh what kind of risk er is it possible
to quantify that we
that we have well i wouldn't venture to
quantify but obviously there are
there are far greater risks this is just
another instance of how
a small group of people amplified
in their impact by modern technology
can have a consequence of cascades
globally this is i don't worry about it
as i put it in my book the global
village will have its village idiots
but they will have a global range now
right which they didn't in the past
and is the biological worry bigger in
your mind than the nuclear worry
i guess there's two categories right
there's sort of poisons like anthrax
that you can spread and then there's
these contagious agents that you can
imagine and they both sound terrible
yes yes well i mean i think the uh the
consequences of
a natural pandemic could be worse of
course some
sars wasn't a global effect because it
only spread to places that could cope
with it i mean singapore
and um and toronto i think mainly but uh
had something like that spread to one of
the mega cities of the developing world
like
mumbai or casablanca or something then
it could have been very very serious
and that's true of any future one and of
course we have plan for
think of that kind how would you cope
would you turn off the mobile phones
because they said panic and rumor
or would you leave them on so you could
spread information you know that's a
sort of sociological
issue which needs to be addressed in
planning for these disasters which
should you do now now you have them are
you curious
well again i don't know but that's an
example of a context where you need
social scientists to uh
explore what is the situation the
optimum thing yeah that's right
and so i think we do need to worry about
natural pandemics and of course
engineered pandemics
and also we certainly have to worry
about the ethical
consequences of new technology already
this is an issue with the uh
the chinese experiments on human embryos
and all that the guy got arrested right
the guy who claimed to have uh
genetically engineered a baby yes and in
fact all the chinese scientists were
equally opposed to what he had done the
balance of benefits and risks was
not such as to justify it whereas one
can justify perhaps a
gene editing if you remove the gene for
hunting disease or something like that
but
what he was doing was deemed by almost
everyone to be unethical
but we do have to worry about the
widespread
understanding and availability of these
techniques
and of course we have to worry about the
social effects
of um these if they can be used for
human enhancement for instance
i mean i think most people think that if
you can uh remove some
severe potentiality to disease then
that's okay but
if you can use genetic modification for
enhancement
um then that's different but fortunately
that's a long way in the future because
most qualities that we might want to
have in human beings
your looks and intelligence etc they're
complicated combinations
there's thousands of genes so before you
can do that you've got to first
use ai on some very large sample of
genomes to decide which combination
optimal
and then be able to synthesize um that
genome
and be confident it's not going to have
unintended downsides so
that's fortunately long way in the
future but if that happened
then that would be a new fundamental
kind of inequality that we'd have to
worry about and and it would perhaps be
bad news because if we think of the
effects of medical advances in the last
century
they've had a beneficial effect on
promoting equality because the
cutting down infection disease in africa
for instance
has had a huge effect on infant
mortality and
brutalized plants yes so i think we can
say looking back
that medical advances have been
beneficial
not just for those who have them but for
promoting
equality worldwide whereas the future
ones may have the reverse effect
in in a sense because we're now
inventing medical procedures that are
just
financially out of the reach of so many
people yeah but it's a good point it's a
good point to sort of segue into
something because
there's the topic of extreme risks and
then there's also the topic of extreme
benefits
and and some some of these technologies
are ambiguous they're transformative
uh you know human gene editing ai uh
more uh things that we're stumbling
across right now in the 21st century
and there's certainly that's certainly
an example where
some people are going to want to just
rush ahead without thinking about the
consequences
well again we can't we can't stop stop
we can't control it just like we can't
control the drug laws or the tax laws
and uh and perhaps
you know in a way um if some crazy
people want to do this perhaps
um we should not be too upset because
obviously
every technology in medicine starts off
as risky i mean heart
heart transplants and things like that
and then become more routine
and so perhaps we should not be too
upset
if a few people try to modify themselves
in ways that
turn out not to be as beneficial as they
hope and of course
techniques like um enhancing your brain
by some
cyborg implant implant into your brain i
mean it would
be great if we could improve our
memories and all that and and so it's
perhaps
a good thing that some people are
talking with a straight face about the
potential of doing this
i mean as you said it's hard but let's
just imagine because that's what we're
doing here in the future let's imagine
someone
develops a diagnostic test that lets you
screen
thousands of embryos and pick out the
one that will be the most intelligent
um and lets prospective parents
take advantage of this technology
would that be bad not necessarily of
course it's interesting to know whether
they would
seek more intelligence because um there
was the famous case of
mr shockley do you remember who oh
shockey the event of the year yeah and
um
he he set up a sperm bank for nobel
prize winners
and i'm glad to say there was very
little demand
i guess that's true that's true but i
just wonder again on a philosophical
level
you know there's a ickiness factor but i
think maybe
you know sort of engineering babies
sounds
weird doctor strangelovey but maybe
there's just an
inevitability about it also like once
people get over that it's going to be
taken for granted well of course we
should make babies as good as we can and
i honestly personally don't have a
strong
understanding in one way or the other no
maybe we should yeah
and uh but there is as you said there is
a yucky factor
about some uh kind of genetic
modification
uh even animals and i think the the
reason why
gm crops were opposed in europe
was that people associated genetic
modification with things like making a
rabbit glow in the dark by putting
jellyfish jeans in it also
something of that kind you know which
which did promote the yuck factor yeah
it's well like circus animals being
given silly clothes to wear every time i
feel it's
it's not what you should do for animals
and people felt the same about that
and that really perhaps went against the
support for the use of gm techniques in
very good cases certainly
uh we can't we can it would be
irresponsible not to mention
everyone's favorite new extreme risk
which is super intelligent artificial
intelligence
right um do you have an opinion on
whether or not that's a real risk or a
fake one well whether it's a risk or
opportunity we don't know but
i think uh obviously the question is um
where this general intelligence we know
already
well we've had for 50 years machines can
do arithmetic better than sure
any human being and of course we've now
got machines who can play
chess better than any human being um and
uh do many other things but
but of course there are still many
things they can't do
as well as a human and and the question
is will they be able to um
acquire common sense as it were they're
acquiring greater capabilities and
and mach and ai is very very valuable
for
coping with um large data sets and
optimizing complex systems
like the electricity grid of a country
the traffic flow
and incidentally the chinese will be
able to have a planned economy
of a kind that marx could only have
dreamt of because they have
uh records they have records of all
transactions
all stocks in the shops etc so that they
could do that so
ai does have tremendous power um to
cope with complex systems but um as
regards
um the sort of robots which we can treat
as intelligent beings
as in the movies you know that's quite a
long way away because
robots are still rather bad at
interacting with
the real environment they can't even
move pieces on a chessboard as well as a
kid can you know
they can't jump from tree to tree as
well as a squirrel can so there's a long
way to go
before uh robots have that sort of uh
agility and interaction
and before they have any feeling for the
external world because
uh someone told me that the um the
watson computer
which uh won the game of jeopardy right
uh was asked
which is bigger a shoebox or mount
everest and couldn't answer
and that's because obviously it doesn't
it understands
but it has no concept of the external
world etc
and to give a machine that concept and
indeed to
get to understand human behavior is a
big challenge
it's a big challenge because from the
computer perspective
everything we do is very very slow and
computers learn by
looking at millions of examples of pages
to translate or
pictures of cats and all that and
recognize them but watching human beings
is like us watching trees grow it's very
slow and they can't
accumulate the uh the amount of data
in order to really understand that and
so that's a big impediment so
that's a long way of saying that i think
it'll be a long time before we have
human general intelligence in the sense
of something which behaves like a human
being although
obviously we will have machines that can
cope with huge data sets
and uh clean up on a stock market and
all those things
right so of course yes the getting uh
artificial intelligence up to general
human scales will will be hard
right but do you think it's possible in
principle there's no
fundamental objection to it i suppose
because you could imagine in principle
uh a machine which has sensors which
allows it to interact with the uh
the real world and uh maybe even
communicate with
with human beings so it's uh not
impossible
um but uh where there'll be a motive for
it right i don't know because i think
one thing we've got to remember is that
uh there's a gap between what could be
done
and uh what this economic or
social motive for doing and that's why
some things surge very very fast
and uh level off just to digress for a
bit um
uh the most rapid technology ever really
is um smartphones which have uh
developed and spread globally
within a decade or so but probably they
will
saturate now the iphone 11 is probably
as complicated as
you want a smartphone to be and so
probably 20 years from now we're using
similar smartphones
and uh a sigmoid curve is what happens
to most individual technologies
and then something else will take over
and i think um
we've got to be mindful of the point
made in the famous book by robert gordon
about the important technological
advances
and he makes the point that what
happened between 1870 and 1950
in electricity the railways television
cars and all that
that was more important than anything
has happened since
and there's something in that and um let
me give you another example
aviation 1919 awkward brown's first
transatlantic flight
50 years after that the first commercial
flight of jumbo jet 1969
and now we're 50 years after that still
the jumbo jet yeah uh
and the concorde came and went and so
that's an example of how
uh technology develops when there's a
motive but then it levels off
uh when things are fine or when there's
no economically feasible
way of developing them further and we
got to realize that that may happen
to um some of these information
technologies
which went very fast so we can't assume
that because they're developing so fast
now
that there will be equally rapid changes
in the next
10 or 20 years but there'll be some
obviously
yeah in the case of the smartphone i
guess the obvious next big phase
transition would be to get a direct
interface with the brain and the
computer right now be very big jump of
course
yes but we're not quite there yet people
are trying but that's not going to be
the next five years
yes okay but still if artificial
intelligence
could be even if it's not precisely
human even if it couldn't pass the
turing test
there is a worry in certain circles that
it will nevertheless be powerful
and it won't have the same values that
we do right you can imagine
something that is hyper-intelligent
along some axes
and yet isn't all that interested in
human flourishing
is that something you worry about well
of course you've got to
worry about two things first of course
if we have the internet of things
then of course that means that uh it's
hard to
avoid a scenario where an ai can
interact with a real external world
it can't be kept in his box but the
question is does it have its
what motives would it have we just don't
know i think it's not it has motives but
it may
do things uh which are contrary to human
interest obviously
that's a possibility that's true of any
machine
and is there any way to i mean we can
sit and fret about it
is there any strategy for uh planning
for that i mean
you know many big names have started
warning about this but i'm not quite
sure what the actual
thing to do is well i don't see it in
principle different from
avoiding the misuse of any other
technology really
so don't worry so much about that not
worried so much about that okay
very good what are you what is your more
positive spin on what ai can do for us
or what you know these kinds of
technologies
well i think it's clear it can optimally
cope with
networks electricity grids and things of
that kind
and obviously it can help
scientists with discoveries i mean i
think um to take one example
if you want to have a room temperature
superconductor then as you know
the best bets are these rather
complicated
compounds materials and rather than do
lots of experiments
then maybe ai can can explore the
parameter space
and come up with that and ditto with
drug development
so i think it can help and um perhaps
moving closer to our own field of
science i think
it may help us to understand some
fundamental problems in cosmology
because supposing that some version of
string theory is correct
and that theory applies to the early
universe
it could very well be that it's just too
difficult
for any human being to work through all
these alternative geometries in
ten dimensions etcetera which you know
i'm all about than me
it may just be too difficult but on the
other hand just as
um a computer learned to play
world-class chess in three hours
given just the rules then it could very
well be
that a machine could do the relevant
manipulations and calculations
in order to follow through the
consequences
of a specific string theory
on the variety string theories and of
course if it
turned out that at the end it spewed out
the right mass of the proton
things like that then we'd know it was
on the right lines and this may be a
kind of
scientific discovery where it never
gives any human
an insight because it's just too
complicated but nonetheless we would
know
that it was uh developing a correct
theory and so i think we have to
bear in mind that there may be some
theories
which are correct but we can never sort
of have the insight into them
which we hope to have into the theories
of physics at the present time simply
because they're too complicated
but nonetheless we would have confidence
in them
because it would do a calculation and it
would come out with
answers which you could compare with
experiment for numbers of neutrinos
masses etc
and if we had such a theory we would
then
believe its predictions about the early
big bang right
because uh those things here is supposed
to apply to the conditions
early on and so we would have reasons to
be able to decide whether many big bangs
are not one what what they like and all
that
and so i think this is just an example
of
how in science the capability of a
machine to do
very very complicated manipulations of
10 dimensional geometry
which i think is a less remote goal and
understanding human behavior it's just
the kind of thing computers could be
good at
and that could be very very important
for science
the extreme kind of physics that we are
interested in ourselves
but also um developing temps high tc
superconductors
and drugs and all that so i think the
power of ai
to do not just routine computations but
to explore parameter space and learn
is going to be very powerful and
beneficial it's been a while now
since the four color theorem was proven
and i remember vividly
right but that's an example of that
that's an example of a computer doing
something in inside
essentially but there again one knew
what it was doing that's i think
in the case of of string theory we may
not understand what
it's doing it's just like in some of the
very clever moves that the uh
alphago zero made playing go the um
experts didn't understand how it chose
that move
and i think it it may be more like that
i think in the four color theorem
everyone knew exactly what the program
was doing etc
uh whereas this might be qualitatively
different from that
in that we don't really understand
what's going on
and of course this is a problem with the
ai already because um
you know if if decisions about um
whether you
should be led out of prison whether you
deserve credit or whether you need an
operation
if they're made by a machine then you're
a bit worried
about that even if you have evidence the
machine on the whole makes better
more reliable judgment than human you
feel you're entitled to an explanation
you can understand
uh but of course that's not always the
case uh when computers are now used
and it may never be the case if they're
used to solve these very difficult
scientific problems which
which involve a huge amount of
calculation yeah there's a whole regime
in which we can imagine computers
solving problems and then not
being able to tell us why they got the
solution that they did
and scientifically that would seem to be
not really satisfying in some way like
we would think that there's further work
to be done if that's all we had well
that's right because obviously what what
the satisfaction of science is that
is uh having some idea and then you get
the
aha insight uh when you realize it's
just got to be that way and that's the
most exciting thing that happens to you
if you're a scientist
but we would never have that but
nonetheless if if it um
spews out the correct values for the
fundamental constants and things like
that
um then you'd have to accept that it's
really
got some insights yes what are your
feelings about
uploading a human brain into a computer
well i mean is it ever going to be
feasible i don't know
um but but then of course the question
is um
would it really be you yes um because uh
i think our personality depends on our
bodies and our interaction our sense
organ so would it be you
and so again what philosophers discuss
is um
if you're told this has been done are
you happy to say well you could be
destroyed because you're
there and what happens if several clones
are made of you
which is really you so so i think
they're all kinds of uh fascinating
philosophical conundrums which
philosophers have talked about for a
long time but of course
maybe one day they will be practical
ethics if we can do things like that
um but i think we do need to worry
about where this is possible and of
course um if we think a few centuries
ahead
then even without that some human
enhancement may have changed
human beings and we're not evolving on
the timescale to indian selection
evolving much faster or we could do
through
through these techniques and um uh one
other point i make in my book is that
when we read the
literature left by the greeks and romans
then we can appreciate it because human
nature was the same then so
we have some affinity with the emotions
of those ancient artists and writers
whereas a few hundred years from now any
intelligences which are still around
may have no more than an algorithmic
understanding of us because they may be
especially different
that they don't have anything that we
would call human emotions
and human nature so that's going to be a
real game changer
but that could happen over a few
centuries
because of human machine interfaces
or human interfaces or uh drastic
genetic modification
yeah human enhancement right which you
were talking about i do think that also
longevity is a is a frontier that might
change things right
dramatically if that happened yes indeed
yes um and uh
it could and and and of course people
are working on this as you know and some
people think that
aging is a disease that can be cured
some people think of just incremental
improvements but of course
if aging can be slowed down so people
live to be 200
this of course would be a huge uh
sociological
change and um again if this was
available to only some subset of people
this would be a huge and fundamental
inequality and the question is
what would go with your
multi-generational families or would you
delay the menopause and all that you
know it'd be crucially different
and so we'd have to be very worried
about what would happen
if changes of that kind were possible
but again
we can't exclude them i don't think um
and of course
we know that people like mr ray kurzweil
who think that uh
they'll be immortal either by that way
or by being able to download them and
they're
the people who want to have their bodies
frozen
in order that they can be resurrected
yeah when
when this happens and um given all the
existential risks that we have talked
about that doesn't seem like the best
strategy to me
no but in fact uh uh amused that um
three
people i know i don't say that from
oxford not from my university
have paid good money to be frozen by
this company in
arizona okay uh i think it's eighty
thousand dollars
a cut price if it's just your head being
frozen and
um and uh and you know they hope this
company will keep going for a few
centuries and then they can be
revived and of course they've got to
have their blood replaced by liquid
nitrogen
etc and they go around carrying some
medallions so that people know that that
should be done as soon as they drop dead
they have to be seen
yeah so i think i also think actually
it's selfish because
supposing that this worked then they'd
be revived
into a inconceivably different world
they'd be refugees from the past and
there'd be a burden
i mean you know we feel that we've got
to uh look after refugees
or some people from amazonian tribes
habit has been destroyed
but if these people voluntarily as
refugees from the past
impose a burden on on you then maybe
they can put you in a zoo or something
like that but
uh it's not clear that it's an ethical
thing to do i think i'm on your side but
you know for purposes of playing devil's
advocate here um
it's there's a similar calculation that
we do with the existential risks if you
thought that
there is a 100th of one percent chance
that 300 years from now we cure aging
and you can literally live forever yes
yes
then clearly the benefit to you of
being frozen even if it doesn't work
very well uh
is almost infinite right there's there's
definitely calculation that ends up with
the conclusion you should do everything
you can
to try to preserve yourself yeah yes yes
and
the chance is here if you don't do this
right that's right
so what about then um as another
survival strategy
going into space i know that elon musk
has said that one of his motivations for
spacex is to uh back up the biosphere by
making sure we have some of us
on other planets if something goes
dramatically wrong here on earth
is that a good survival strategy for the
human race well i'm a bit skeptical
about these arguments
i mean of course i i'm especially
interested in space being an astronomer
and i think um ai
and miniaturization is going to be
crucially important
uh for the science of space exploration
um
i think would be wonderful probe sent
into space cassini
orbiting around saturn his moons and all
that
and um new horizons which took pictures
of pluto new orleans
but all those were 1990s technology
and because so they took ten years ago
and
let's get there and if you think of how
things like smartphones have changed
since then we realize how much better we
can do now and so i really hope that
there'll be swarms
of miniaturized probes going
throughout the solar system to exploit
in in detail
i think that's realistic um and uh also
i'm wandering around on the surface of
mars etc
um but as regards people then
with every advance in miniaturization
robotics
the practical need for the people gets
less
and that's one reason why of course
man's space flight has not been
prioritized so much um of course there
is a revival of interest
and um i personally think that if i was
an american
i would want any taxpayers money to go
on nasa's man program
because there's no practical need for
the people but on the other hand
i'd be glad that mr musk and the others
are
developing very effective
rockets bringing silicon valley culture
um to a a branch of
industry that was dominated by the big
conglomerates like lockheed are doing
great stuff there
and i hope that they will
be sending people into space
but they'll be adventurous prepared to
accept a high risk because
one reason why the nasa man program was
very expensive
was it was very risk-averse the shuttle
was launched i think 135 times
and there were two failures less than
two percent failure rate
but each of those failures was a big
national trauma because it was presented
as safe and they sent up a
woman's school teacher and all that you
know so i personally think that um
space should be left for adventurers the
kind of people who
hang glide in yosemite and things like
that and are prepared to accept a very
high risk right the risk is just costs
are doing business and that's built
yeah yeah and there are people obviously
um adventurers who are prepared to take
take that risk and even a one-way ticket
to go to mars and um
but ellen musk has said he hopes to die
on mars but not on impact and good luck
to him
uh and we should admire these people and
cheer them on um
but um i think the idea of mass
emigration
is a rather dangerous delusion okay
because we got to realize that dealing
with climate change for instance
is a challenge but it's a doddle
compared to terraforming mars right
um and so i think we got to accept that
um there's no planet b for ordinary
risk-averse people
and so uh we should encourage people to
go to mars but uh
um that's less comfortable than living
at the south pole not many people want
to do that
right um so i think we should encourage
it um
and i think actually looking further
ahead
i think we should cheer on those who do
try to establish a colony on mars even
though it'll be against the odds
uncomfortable
and that's because those people will
have
every incentive to use all the
techniques of genetic modification and
cyborg
techniques to adapt themselves we're
pretty well adapted to living on the
earth
but they they be in an environment to
which they're very badly adapted
so they have every incentive to use
these techniques to adapt to different
gravity different atmospheres etc
um and um and maybe if possible to
download themselves into some
electronic form and if they do that
then they may prefer zero g and they may
not need to be on a planet at all you
know um so um i think that these
post-human
developments which will happen on a
technological time scale
far faster than the darwinian time scale
they will happen fastest among
these crazy adventurers who try to live
on mars
and so the post-human era will start
from them
it does seem almost inevitable that the
first trip to mars will be a one-way
trip
yes it's so hard to come back and that
is a good argument that it won't be done
by a government right
nasa would never send astronauts to mars
not
volunteers to go one way right but the
government would be having a hard time
and we and of course uh um i think as
human beings
we should admire and cheer on these
people because um
uh they may indeed hold the post-human
future in their hands
and i i guess i hadn't thought of the
idea
that people who dwell in space whether
it's on mars or
in between um would be natural
candidates for genetic modification but
it makes perfect sense
so in some sense a different species
they'd become a different species yes
and of course whether they would be
entirely flesh and blood or whether they
will by then be uh
cyborgs or even downloads into something
electronic um
we don't know but if they become purely
electronic
then of course um they won't want to
stay on the planet
and of course if they're near immortal
and interstellar voyage is no deterrent
to them
and so they will spread and um this has
relevance in my view to seti
projects because um you know uh i think
obviously the search for
extraterrestrial
biospheres is a mainstream part of
science now that we know that the
exoplanets out there many like the earth
and within 10 or 20 years we know if any
of them have biospheres
but of course what people really want to
know is are there
any um intelligent aliens out there
and that's why there are the seti
programmes to look for
[Music]
extraterrestrial artifacts or
transmissions which are manifestly
artificial
and i'm an enthusiast for modest
expenditures on all these
possible searches because it's so
fascinating to all of us
but if you ask what i would predict i
predicted if anything is detected
it won't be any sort of flesh and blood
civilization on a planet
it will be some sort of um
maybe burping and malfunctioning
artifacts
um probably roaming in space and the
reason for that is
um let's suppose that there is another
planet where things have are rather like
on the earth
and what's happened here on earth is
four billion years of dominion evolution
and we're now in a few millennia of
technological
um civilization but within a few hundred
years
as we've discussed it may have been
taken over
by some sort of electronic entities
not flesh and blood and they
in principle have a billionaire future
ahead of them because they
may be immortal and they can create
copies or developments of themselves etc
um and so if there was another planet
where
things had happened differently it's
unlikely to be synchronized
to within a few millennia so that we
would detect a citizen like ours it's
not at the same stage of technology
so um so if it's behind by
a few tens of millions of years then of
course we see no evidence of
intelligence we see a biosphere
if it's a head then of course we would
uh
not detect anything like what's now on
earth
but we might detect some technological
artifacts
or their their emissions and so that's
why
if we do detect something it's far more
likely to be
something like that detect um some
electronic artifact
um yeah i i personally think that the
and you have to modify the drake
equation because the trace talks about
the
lifetime of civilization thinking about
something
um with lots of independent fresh and
blood entities
whereas it may be one super brain and
maybe something entirely electronic
and and that could persist for
billions of years even if a civilization
like ours can't persist for more than
thousands of years
i've often thought that the idea of
taking a big radio telescope
and listening in on the sky for other
advanced civilizations was
a very very very long shot because why
in the world would advanced civilization
waste a bunch of energy beyond radio
signals in random directions
yeah yes um but i think you know um it's
sensible to do everything we can
everything as a byproduct of it's
relatively serious
yes yes and so so i mean i support their
efforts to look for radio
transmissions uh narrow frequencies
and look for optical flashes and things
like that um
and uh we should also look for
for artifacts we should look for
evidence of some
star that's uh orbited by something
that's manifestly artificial
we should even look for artifacts in our
solar system um
uh some something in the asteroid belt
that's specially shiny et cetera
on the moon two thousand aluminum yes
i mean one argument is that if
intelligent life
formed frequently it would build
self-replicating robots and it should
have filled the galaxy a long time ago
right and this leads to the fermi
paradigm yes uh well of course
the fame pedal is is one important
relevant fact about this but
i think um a reason why i don't think
it's a
watertight argument is that um if these
um
future entities are electronic it's not
clear they will be expansionist because
you know we have evolved by dominion
selection which favors intelligence
but also favors aggression um and so
that's why people talk about uh
uh you know a sphere of interest
expanding and uh et cetera and the
aliens that have come here but um if if
the
intelligences are electronic
then they may be entirely conservative
they may not want to expand and so
they could be out there without
manifesting their presence in they can
speak his way
and come here so i don't think we can
say that the
galaxy doesn't contain anything like
that we can say that um
um it can't contain many civilizations
which have led to massive expansion
right because we've some would have got
here already but i think
if the scenario is that advanced
intelligence is electronic
then that need not be associated with
expansionism
the flip side of that though is is i
wondered about this
out loud you know is it possible that we
do sort of
gradually or suddenly upload our
consciousness
into electronics and then exactly
because we don't have all these
sort of thermodynamic survival instincts
anymore
we stop caring you know even forget
about expanding just existing
is less interesting to us in that
environment
the survival instinct is no longer there
i think we as human beings
probably want to stay as human beings
and and
and i think we we'd like to feel that
the earth
won't change very much that's why um i'm
happy about all these things happening
fast
right uh away from the earth but uh
preserving the earth as it is
occupied by creatures who are adapted to
it
making now so in addition to human
beings there would be artificial
intelligent
electronic beings that we could spread
throughout the galaxy
yeah yes and we hope they leave us alone
got it but
i i think we would i think want to try
and restrain
this speed of these changes because
maybe we can't
because maybe some
group will get ahead and and we'll have
a sort of very um
uh disturbed world where human beings
can't survive and
this is one of the dystopian scenarios
obviously right but i think we should
hope that uh
things don't change too fast is it so
you
see your perspective seems to indicate
that the fermi paradox might not be a
very big paradox and in fact that
the galaxy might be teeming with
different kinds of life is that your is
that fair
yes yes and so what does that say to
people who are thinking about
the origin of life or the the frequency
of life so i know that there's certainly
an
idea that we haven't seen lots of aliens
yet
therefore the very beginning of life was
a really really really unlikely event or
the beginning of multicellular life was
very hard
yes well i mean um it's of course if you
take the female
seriously um then you could still
be happy with the idea that simple life
and the biosphere of lots of plants and
things
could be widespread yeah and uh within
20 years
we will know that because we'll have a
spectroscopy of planets around nearby
stars
which will be sufficient to tell us if
there's a if there's a biosphere there
um but even if a biosphere of
plants and simple organisms is common
on earth-like planets throughout the
galaxy it could still be
that there are um other bottlenecks
which stop it getting to intelligence
so uh i think we can still hope
even if we don't think that intelligent
life is widespread
that simple biospheres are widespread
because we don't know what the odds were
against
um the evolution getting as far as as
it has i mean if the dinosaurs had been
wiped out
would there would there be an
intelligence like us that have
emerged by a different group we just
don't know well europa or titan might
have biospheres right
well titan might and and of course um
the origin of life
is a problem which everyone has known is
an
important problem but most people
most serious scientists have put it in
this sort of too difficult box
um and uh haven't worked on it right
evidence of that is that the
miller yuri experiment done near 1950s
where they
put sparks through a gas and got amino
acid acids and all that
that experiment was still talked about
40 years later where people could
no one thought of doing much better
experiments you know whereas now
the lots of serious top-ranking bulgers
who are thinking about the origin of
life and the stages by which
it could happen um as motivated by
advances in
microbiology but also of course
motivated by realizing that there are
other
places in the in the galaxy where it
could exist
and and so i'm hopeful uh from having
talked to a number of these people
that we will have a plausible scenario
for the origin of life
within 10 or 20 years and that'll tell
us two things
it'll tell us first was it a rare fluke
but it
it would tell us also in answer to your
question um does it
depend completely on special chemistry
like the nrna
does it even depend on water as a
solvent because in
titan of course you don't have methane
yeah and not water and
uh and i think if we understood the
original life we would know
whether whatever happened at the tempt
of the earth with water
could have happened on titan or not so
we will know
how rare the origin of life is and
what the variety of chemistries is that
could lead to it so we don't know that
but i think in the next 20 years
we'll know about that um and we also
might have evidence for whether there is
life and of course some um telescopes
now
aren't really powerful enough to um
be able to detect a spectrum
of a planet because an earth-like planet
is billions of times fainter than the
stars orbiting
and to isolate the spectrum of that is
very hard um so i think we
the james webb telescope might do
something but after that
the um best bet is going to be the
telescope the europeans are building
which is called
um the extremely large telescope uh
but this has a 39 meter mirror which is
a not one sheet of glass but a mosaic of
800
pieces of glass and this will collect
enough light
such that with the right spectrograph it
should be able to separate out
the the light reflected from the planet
from the billions time brighter light
from the uh
the star and so we can really see
and as the planets in different phases
then you change that and so
that would tell us something about uh
you know about the chlorophyll on the
planet and things of that kind
yeah um so that's something which will
be done within
10 or 20 years yeah that's a very and
just so everyone knows the
extremely large telescope is a
ground-based telescope it's
groundbreaking yes yes
james webb is is in space um and uh
it's not obviously it's advantage in
space but you can have a much bigger
mirror on the ground but incidentally if
you look further ahead
then talk about robots
even if we don't send many people into
space
we can have robotic fabricators
assembling big structures
either on the moon or maybe in space and
and i i think
uh one exciting scenario
is uh fabricating one huge
very lightweight mirror under zero g in
space which might even be able to uh
resolve the image of an exoplanet okay
not just to take the light but see it as
an extended object not just
as a point and i think um uh
my point in my book that the target for
this
should be 2068 which is
a centenary of the famous picture taken
by hernandez
earthrise which was the um classic
iconic picture of the earth
right and it would be nice if 100 years
after that
we had a picture we could put on our
walls of
an earth-like planet elsewhere and it
would not be crazy to have
by that time a successor of james webb
telescope
and of the elt which could be a huge
mirror up in space
how huge is huge how big how big do you
need for the mirror oven space to do
this
i think several hundred meters several
hundred meters okay that sounds feasible
to me
what do i know but under zero g it would
not be impossible that's right
okay uh you mentioned just to sort of
start winding things up we can get back
to the ethical concerns a little bit
because you did mention
terraforming mars yes if human beings
want to go up there and
start living there there are people who
will say that we shouldn't
do that right this is a whole part of
nature
and uh what do you think well i mean i
think um
if there were evidence of uh of life
there
then i think most people would feel we
ought to sort of
preserve that life like a national park
as it were
if there's no life at all um then i
think we could be somewhat more relaxed
about it
similarly about the moon i mean i i
think um
you know people talk about mining the
moon um
in fact um harrison schmidt has this
idea of
of of really sort of doing a huge amount
of uh
open cast mining and the moon to find
helium-3
and um you know i think economically
that doesn't make much sense
and probably never will but on the other
hand uh the question is would we
be relaxed about it and uh i personally
would be fairly relaxed
about um getting materials from the moon
in order to build structures on the moon
um preserving a few historic sites like
where the apollo astronauts landed
and things of that kind but if there
were a biosphere already
then i think most people would feel that
once you try and uh preserve it
on mars or indeed under the
ice of enceladus or europa which of
course
uh are now thought to be perhaps the
most likely places for
life in our solar system and of course
um there are pro
probes um already being planned to um
to fly through the spray that's coming
up
right through cracks in the ice there to
be able to do some analysis to see if
there's complex chemistry
chemistry there and of course looking
further ahead to send some submarine to
go down and see if there's something
swimming around
we're gonna so minescape listeners
should know we will be talking about
exactly that yeah
yes yes very exciting but but i think um
the reason that's important isn't well
not any of his own
important exploration but of course if
we could find evidence that earth that
life had originated twice
independently within our solar system
that would tell us straight away that
life
of some kind was widespread like a
billion places in our galaxy it would be
one of the most important discoveries of
all time it would
it would indeed but but it's got to be
convincingly independent and that's why
some people would say life on mars
would not be quite so convincing because
people have said
maybe we're all martians maybe life
starts on miles and then
um meteorites brought it to the earth or
vice versa yes
whereas if it was um uh on europa i
think you couldn't make that argument
would be
independent and of course if it was
quite different chemistry chemistry
then that also would show independence
and so that's why
i think searches for even rather boring
primitive life
anywhere in our solar system are very
important because uh
it would have such huge implications uh
for the
prevalence of life throughout the entire
galaxy you've made bets before
uh what would be your bets about uh both
the existence of life elsewhere
and our likelihood of finding it well i
think i would
bet substantial odds on finding evidence
somewhere
of life whether whether it will be
in europa or enceladus
moons of saturn or jupiter or whether it
will be
from observations of exoplanets like the
earth
and of course we shouldn't just look at
things like the earth we should i think
look at other planets in other places um
so um
i i think it's not uh a crazy
expectation um whereas the the idea of
um
finding intelligent life or or
artifacts which are evidence that there
was some sort of
intelligent life um uh obviously i'm in
favor of
pursuing research at a modest level
because it's so fascinating to everyone
you know if people know i'm an
astronomer
then the first question they ask is is
are we alone etc they all ask that
question and they want to talk about it
if you don't want to talk to your
neighbor on the plane you say
mathematician we're a physicist but it's
already works
yes um but uh even though i
favor and support modern searches for
intelligent signals of some kind or
artifacts
um i wouldn't bet very much on that
right but it's so important it's worth a
search
yeah it's a good point i'll i'll close
by mentioning i don't know if i've ever
told you this but um
some time ago roughly 20 years ago you
gave a public lecture
in chicago and i was in the audience and
so i was already you know a cosmologist
physicist
uh giving lectures myself but you were
talking about cosmology in the state of
cosmology
and in the middle of the talk you
started talking about the possibility of
life
on other planets in other solar systems
and as a professional scientist of
course i was appalled by this i'm like
that's not cosmology at all
but i realized of course like you just
said that is what people care about
and upon reflection i gathered a
important lesson from that which is that
it's okay to talk about what people care
about
not just what you as a professional are
supposed to be
talking about yeah yes yes but i think
it's more than that i think um
there are some subjects which are so far
from
any kind of empirical test that's it's
not worth discussing them
um and uh there should be left in the
two difficult box and left alone
and uh that may have been true in the
past
of many of these issues but i think um
exobiology is now a serious subject
um and so i think no one would regard it
as a crazy flaky
cranky subject as they might have done
in the past
that's right and uh the very
the very practice of contemplating the
future seems to be a very different
thing now than it was 50 years ago so
it's interesting to see how our
perspective has changed
it hasn't but i think that when i'm
asked is there any special perspective
that i bring to these uh
issues of the earth's future because i'm
an astronomer and cosmologist
it is simply an awareness of the
long-term future because
most people unless they live in kentucky
or some muslim areas
are happy with the idea where the
outcome of four billion years of
evolution
but nonetheless frame anything we're the
top of the tree where the combination of
evolution
and i think that's something which no
astronomer could believe being aware of
the huge
ranges of future time and uh
extended space it's a very good
perspective to keep in mind martin ruiz
thanks so much for being on the podcast
thank you very much
[Music]
you